para ayudarnos a entender cómo funciona
la comunicación entre células quiero que
recordemos los días de la escuela
primaria en particular quiero que
pienses en las cosas que tenías que
hacer para poder hablar en secreto con
tus amigos durante la clase así que aquí
estás sentado en la clase y
desesperadamente quieres decirle algo a
tu amigo entonces le escribes una
pequeña nota y se la pasas desde tu mano
directamente hasta su mano así él ve la
nota pero nadie más puede verla
ahora digamos que quieres decirle algo a
tu amigo que está del otro lado del
salón no sé tú pero cuando yo iba en la
primaria solía escribir notas en pedazos
de papel que después doblaba en forma de
avión y tenía bastante buena puntería en
ese entonces así que lanzaba el avión de
papel a través de todo el salón hasta
llegar a mi amigo una vez más solo él
veía el mensaje ya que a nadie más le
llegaba mi pequeño avión de papel ahora
bien si quería decirle a algunos amigos
algo podré llamar a un pequeño grupo y
decirle algunas cosas solo a este grupo
de amigos de aquí entonces mi voz
solamente cruzaban esta pequeña
distancia entre nosotros
sin embargo pasemos al siguiente nivel
yo fui un poco rebelde en la escuela
primaria y algunas veces iba al
escritorio de la secretaria tomaba el
control del intercomunicador y les decía
cosas
a mis amigos les decía por ejemplo que
me encontraran en el asta bandera en el
recreo o lo que sea ese mensaje que
mandaba por el intercomunicador llegaba
a todos debido a que era transmitido en
toda la escuela así que todos los que
querían encontrarme iban al asta bandera
y los que no no
podemos pensar que las células son como
pequeñas personas y hacen cosas muy
similares puede que no siempre pensemos
en esto pero es muy muy importante que
las células sean capaces de comunicarse
entre ellas en términos de evolución una
razón importante del por qué somos tan
complejos como seres humanos es que las
células son capaces de comunicarse entre
sí a medida de que avancemos en el vídeo
daremos algunos ejemplos de cómo se
comunican las células entonces cómo es
que las células se pasan notas entre
ellas cómo es que se comunican
directamente bueno una forma es por
contacto directo las células tienen un
montón de proteínas ancladas a sus
membranas plasmáticas que sirven para
muchas funciones y la más importante es
la comunicación
por ejemplo aquí tenemos un macrófago
este es un tipo de célula blanca que es
parte de tu sistema inmunitario y cuando
estos macrófagos ven un invasor extraño
tal vez una pequeña bacteria o un virus
lo pueden ingerir
descomponerlo y presentar en su
superficie pequeñas piezas de él
que ahora reciben el nombre de antígeno
así que lo presenta en su superficie en
una de las proteínas que se encuentran
aquí en particular a esta se le conoce
como proteína complejo mayor de
histocompatibilidad 2 ahora este pequeño
antígeno se ha convertido en la nota que
se quiere compartir el antígeno es el
mensaje
entonces cuando otra célula blanca tal
vez una célula t colaboradora llega y
toma este antígeno de aquí con una de
sus proteínas ancladas a la membrana en
este caso este es el receptor de la
célula t colaboradora solo al hacer esto
este macrófago pasa el mensaje a la
célula t colaboradora
ahora dependiendo de cuál sea el
antígeno en cuestión la célula te puede
decidir ya sea tener una respuesta
inmunitaria completa o tal vez hacer
sonar las alarmas activando a otras
células inmunitarias que se llaman
células ven o no es decir también puede
decidir no hacer nada todo dependerá de
la clase de nota que sea entonces no
sorprende que cuando las células se
tocan directamente para comunicarse a
esto se le llama comunicación celular
celular
directa o simplemente unión directa
ahora bien que otros métodos de
comunicación existen bueno las células
también pueden comunicarse a distancias
cortas
esto sería nuestro avión de papel por
ejemplo vamos a fijarnos en dos neuronas
están muy cerca una de la otra pero el
extremo de una neurona no toca el inicio
de la otra hay un pequeño espacio por
aquí que se llama
sináptica lo que hacen las neuronas es
liberar pequeñas señales llamadas
neurotransmisores para comunicarse entre
ellas entonces la neurona liberan
neurotransmisores desde su extremo y se
difunden a lo largo de esta distancia
hasta que se unen a las dendritas de la
siguiente neurona esto pasa el mensaje
de manera efectiva de esta neurona a la
siguiente
el avión de papel se lanza de aquí a acá
a esto se le conoce como comunicación
neuronal y por aquí parecido a llamar a
un grupo una célula puede hablar
localmente con un pequeño grupo de
células por ejemplo justo debajo de tu
piel digamos la piel dentro de tu nariz
tenemos estas células inmunitarias
llamadas mastocitos que son mediadores
realmente importantes en reacciones
alérgicas y es por ello que elegimos a
la nariz así que imagina que eres
alérgico a un cierto polen
o un día en primavera te encuentras
caminando a través de un parque e
inevitablemente respiras un poco de ese
polen entonces el polen se pega a estos
anticuerpos unidos a los mastocitos y
como respuesta los mastocitos liberarán
señalizadores químicos llamados
histaminas entonces la estamina actúa
como un mensaje de corto alcance viaja
alrededor de las células en esta área y
les hace saber que se ha encontrado un
alérgeno para que se empiecen a preparar
para la reacción alérgica que viene en
camino este tipo de comunicación se
llaman señalización para karina que
significa local
finalmente llegamos al intercomunicador
cómo es que se comunican las células con
grandes grupos de células al mismo
tiempo bueno lo hacen por medio de la
señalización endocrina por ejemplo las
células en la glándula pituitaria en tu
cerebro hacen muchas de las hormonas
importantes de tu cuerpo
así que imaginemos que están haciendo
las hormonas del crecimiento gh para
mandarlas a todas las células de tu
cuerpo
aquí mandar esta hormona es su forma de
comunicación así que crean las hormonas
del crecimiento dentro de sus cuerpos
celulares y las liberan al torrente
sanguíneo
entonces las hormonas del crecimiento
pueden viajar a través del torrente
sanguíneo y así llegar a cualquier parte
de tu cuerpo entonces cada célula de tu
cuerpo tiene la oportunidad de recibir
este mensaje de la hormona del
crecimiento esto no quiere decir que
todas las células tengan que responder a
este
ya que necesariamente ya que algunas
células tal vez no tengan las proteínas
adecuadas para unirse a ciertas hormonas
pero de cualquier forma puedes ver que
esta es una forma de comunicación a
larga distancia